lors du congrès annuel de la Société
Européenne d'ontologie médicale une
équipe anglaise a dévoilé une étude sur
le rôle des particules fines dans le
développement du cancer du poumon on est
en train de pouvoir indiquer que des
petites particules dans l'air qui vient
avec la pollution peuvent causer
l'émergence de type de cancer que l'on
avait pas vu avant le 20 au 25 ans on
retrouve les particules fines notamment
dans les gaz d'échappement dans la fumée
industrielle ou issue du chauffage au
bois elles sont invisibles à l’œil nu
l'étude anglaise n'a pas encore été
revue par des pères mais elle indique
que les particules fines pourraient
affecter certaines cellules qui elles
déclencheraient des changements dans
deux gènes des alliés au cancer du
poumon
de 2.5 micromètres peuvent causer au
niveau des poumons mais probablement
aussi au niveau de d'autres tissus de
l'inflammation et que cette informe à
inflammation va elle-même causer des
altérations secondaires au niveau des
tissus qui sont atteints et par le fait
même par la suite développé des types de
cancer c'est a commencé importante qui
braque les projecteurs sur l'importance
de la réduction de la pollution le
meilleur moyen de prévenir la maladie
c'est d'enlever les contaminants à la
source pour prévenir encore faudrait-il
avoir un registre des tumeurs au Québec
or il n'y en a pas affirme le docteur
Soulière dans certaines zones du Québec
par exemple une plus grande émergence de
certains types de cancers et en se
demandant qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans
l'environnement à cet endroit là qui
fait en sorte que certains types de
cancers sont plus prévalents que dans
les autres régions selon le ministère de
l'Environnement en 2021 le Québec a vécu
en moyenne 12 jours avec une mauvaise
qualité de l'air or à certains endroits
de la capitale nationale de la bitibite
et misscamang et de la naudière les
résidents en ont subi encore plus soit
entre 31 et 43 jours un enjeu trop peu
abordé durant cette campagne électorale
selon certains ici Marie-José paquet de
comoradi au Canada Montréal